bonsoir stéphane rozès merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors on a vu les
premiers pas du nouveau premier ministre
bien orchestré une interview sur une
chaîne de télévision ensuite une
première visite puis une interview dans
la presse
il devait faire son discours de
politique générale cette semaine on a
appris que c'était finalement emmanuel
macron qui va parler le premier le 14
juillet il renoue donc avec la tradition
ça veut dire quoi selon vous comment
analysez-vous cette communication
mais ça veut dire que dans couple
exécutif clairement il va y avoir un
recentrement à l'église et du pouvoir
quand ces derniers mois on avait pu
s'interroger sur le fait de savoir si
belize et matignon était sur la même
ligne
donc clairement le premier ministre
castex daddy au niveau de bêta c'est la
stratégie et ce sera sans doute des
lycées et puis il ya ensuite
l'application sur le terrain comme si un
détail à l'elysée fixe l obligation de
faim et comme si le premier ministre lui
était le comptable cherche et de
l'abnégation de l'application sur le
terrain sur les territoires et puis de
devoir gérer ça a été dit au quotidien
compliqué lui a annoncé des réformes
reprendre dans la question de la réforme
des retraites réforme du chômage
et puis tout le monde le sait ça a été
dit le terme de choc économique et
social est utilisé pour la rentrée mais
il faudra attendre
l'allocution présidentielle qui va fixer
de cap et le discours de politique
générale du premier ministre ensuite qui
va décliner pour avoir la nature du du
nouveau chemin qu'avait annoncé le
président je rappelle que c'est la
raison pour laquelle les municipales on
était avancé avant l'été des coupes et
des deux premiers tours c'est que nous
attendons le pays attend avec impatience
et inquiétude
le contenu du nouveau chemin annoncée
par le président ce sera très difficile
c'est ce qu'avait dit emmanuel macron
cette rentrée
comment est-ce que vous analysez les
premiers pas de jean castex un bon petit
soldat volontariste oui au fond c'est le
change pour l'instant c'est le
changement dans la continuité
la continuité on l'a dit c'est une
personnalité de droite le changement
c'est un serviteur de l'état il ne vient
pas pour des raisons politiques
contrairement edouard philippe même si
il vient des républicains est autant
edouard philippe était un un homme de
droite je dirais dans un tueur logiciel
juppéiste le premier ministre l'a une
tonalité plus sociale plus sarkozyste
plus gaullisme enfin sarkozys version
gaullisme social
donc c'est un petit changement il a
également un grand talent de négociateur
on l'a vu dans le passé est un grand
talent d'organisateur en amour c'est
vraiment le profil des douanes du point
de vue du président pour mettre en
musique et appliquer des choses et puis
comme ça va être très dur à
économiquement à la rentrée avec des
environs 800 mille chômeurs de plus vous
rendez compte c'est énorme on aura
besoin effectivement de son talent de
dans ses rapports avec les collectivités
territoriales mais même il avait laissé
un bon souvenir aux partenaires sociaux
quand sa façon d'être et de faire avec
eux ce qu'on appelait le soin de son
directeur de cabinet nicolas revel qui
est un très proche des manuels macron ça
veut dire que le président l'elysée
tient les rênes serrées selon vous oui
parce que ou faut au moment des filets
jaunes au moment de la réforme des
retraites
pour ceux qui suivaient attentivement
les choses il y avait deux petites
il y avait des petites différences
d'appréciation entre le président
maquereau et le premier ministre edouard
philippe d'abord sur l'état du pays
et puis sur la façon de conduire les
réformes où l'avez vu dès le départ sur
la sphère des 80 km l'appréciation des
gilets jaunes c'était d'ailleurs le
président m'a conquis qui analysait plus
finement les choses et puis sur la
réforme des retraites clairement
matignon bercy imprimait un contenu de
la réforme des retraites très comptable
alors comme les relations personnelles
entre le président et le premier
ministre était bonne et que le premier
ministre avait un vrai talent pour
s'adapter aux situations ça ne se voyait
pas mais dans la réalité on était passé
d'une posture d'élection du président
néo bonapartiste à une ligne orléaniste
de droite traditionnel hoops au fond on
est pour l'adaptation de la france au
néolibéralisme est faible enfin faire la
française avec le talent des doigts film
on va voir ce qu'il en est est ce que le
président mène inflexion vers
l'indépendance nationale la souveraineté
avec bien sûr un vrai garçon écologistes
ou est-ce qu'au fond on est dans la
continuité de ce qui s'est fait jusqu'à
maintenant mais avec un talent de
communication que porterait jean castex
on le verra au travers de la liste des
ministres retenus leur profil
idéologique et politique au lan la
compétence le président maintenant a
voulu un gouvernement de mission et un
gouvernement de rassemblement
gouvernement munitions ça veut dire sans
doute plus grande efficacité compétents
cinq ans quand même
il y avait des ministres qui étaient pas
la hauteur dans le gouvernement sortant
mais aussi d'union et de rassemblement
et là on va être très attentif aux
équilibres idéologique et politique de
la composition de ce gouvernement entend
ça donnera sans doute une idée du
curseur que veut mettre le président
mâcon quant à la nature
de son nouveau schéma le nouveau chemin
des manuels macron ce nouveau ce
remaniement est ce choix de ce nouveau
premier ministre est ce que c'est aussi
une question électorale
honnêtement si c'était ça le propos du
président macron c'est que décidément il
n'aurait pas vu à la fois le délitement
de son lien avec le pays et les épreuves
velde qui attendent le pays
je parle même pas du risque d'une
deuxième vague de crise sanitaire mais
réellement on comprend dans les termes
qu'il a utilisée dans son interview au
financial times ces différentes
allocutions ses interviews dans la pqr
qui a à juste titre chez le président
bak ont une inquiétude donc est ce qu'on
est en train de guignol on est en train
de dire que la présidentielle il ya des
très loin que deux en deux ans viletta
du pays ville et à l'europe vineta du
monde c'est quand même très très loin
donc je pense que le président est assez
lucide pour pas s'occuper de petites
affaires telles qu'une campagne
présidentielle mais déjà faire en sorte
qu'il arrive avant en état de marche et
donc ça veut dire ce que le pays
non seulement sortent de l'épreuve
actuelle me réoriente des politiques qui
ont mené à la situation dans laquelle on
se trouve aujourd'hui et c'était très
court stéphane rozès pourtant pourtant
edouard philippe a été chargée de
resserrer de reformer en tout cas une
majorité crédible pour 2022
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pourquoi
edouard philippe
alors qu'on lui prête aussi peut-être
quelques velléités de se présenter à
cette présidentielle on y voit pas très
clair
ben justement votre question est dans
votre interrogation c'est justement
parce qu' edouard philippe populaire
parce qu'au fond ils semblaient durant
la tristesse sanitaires plus qu en
cohérence entre ce qui est dit et ce qui
était fait mais il s'agit pour le
président mâcon de s'assurer d'edouard
philippe ne soit pas candidat possible
et donc qui lui donne une mission qui
est justement de s'occuper d'eux
ou qui se sont un tout petit peu dit p
dispersé de sorte que cette nouvelle
mission tienne edouard philippe contrer
avec le président merci beaucoup
stéphane rozès pour votre analyse est
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france